il donc il paraît qu'il faut qu'on
interviewe de petites jeunes
oui s'étaient branchés de la dominer de
lacoste et nicolas veut jacquat chapelle
grosjean des demoiselles et dames
donc il vous fait dans la théâtre mais
vous n'êtes pas très connu à moi je vous
ai jamais vu à la télé vous faites quoi
donc comme j'en avais les ventes
nicolas vivant devient touchant six
manches tous les jours vous allez dire
comme ça parce qu'on peut pas dire
qu'elles sont plutôt rapides et dans ce
genre eh oui mais sous tellement
sympathique et puis des femmes comme ça
on en voit tous les jours tous les jours
un petit enfant quand même pas exagérer
vous l'avez vous la grosse colère et
puis à mes copains elle est bientôt
coinchée pour que je sois en train mon
nom là vous poussez un peu
non les gens comme ça ça existe
seulement c'est que c'est qu'ils se
regardent pas ce qui se voit pas les
gens c'est tout mais dit chez vrai que
j'allais arrêter de faire les ans parce
que finalement non les premiers quand
même un peu inquiet car on va devenir
quoi dans tout ça ah ben moi je veux
continuer personnage de gizeh je vais
jouer avec eux avec le neveu de 1,9
lucienne qui s'appelle robert vous
disais bien aussi et vous nicole
bouchard était vraiment oui moi j'arrête
je faire de la peinture j'écris en ce
moment un livre de nouvelles
et puis surtout j'ai envie d'avoir un
enfant alors lucienne sechin défini est
bon la page d'erreur varie que j'ai fini
alors j'ai vraiment flippé quand on vous
dit que ça fait d'y aller au 20e voix
qui gêne la motion d'appui quasi renvoie
finalement ben oui en tout cas on s'est
bien amusé avec ses personnages des
ventes
c'est vrai oui enfin sosie de temps en
temps les 120 kg jesus c'était plutôt
lourd à porter lourd à porter la balle
dedans oui le pain non non je crois que
t'as pas fini de mini tient inquiète pas
je suis raide soutenir le moral à la
première de son prochain spectacle en
février pas de problème étant j'espère
que tu me verras un carton d'invitation
pour une expo en mars et bâché d'accord
à la prochaine on fait comme ça bonjour
chez vous décidément s'en sortira jamais
de foot et là vous bastia il faut dire
ça nous est venu casser les cadors
également chez un paquet pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus